how's your as my Empress Pass what do
you say for the flowers the ice bucket
challenge you hit 30 million subscribers
where's the video I've been on vacation
for a week it's it's been great so
that's why I'm I'm a little behind on
some videos I know but I wanted to start
off and say thank you bros so much for
30 million bros that's like more than
most countries
how'd it how does that even work when
are we invading Norway already
we'll start with Norway will end with
Sweden it really means a lot to me that
you brought again you're ruining my my
moment
Edgar has learned how to open doors
anyway it means a lot to me that you
bros support my videos and to have 30
million people do that that's pretty
amazing nice to say that
Who am I kidding it's [ __ ] awesome so
thank you from the bottom of my precious
little heart thank you I'm not gonna do
the ice bucket challenge I'm very sorry
it's not gonna make a difference if I if
I do it or not everyone knows about the
ice bucket challenge by this point so
instead I wanted to do what it seems
like a lot of people who do the ice
bucket challenge don't do which is talk
about ALS explain what ALS is I mean
that was the point right so for those of
you who don't know the point of pouring
ice water over your head is to simulate
or I don't know at least a second what
it feels like to have ALS I've seen ALS
I've seen it in its early stages what it
does to people and it is probably the
scariest thing that can happen to
you just imagine yourself your finger
sub working you lose the ability to
speak your arms are barking you can't
walk you can't do anything yourself and
your mind is still clear but you're
trapped in this body that you can't move
it's just awful and after that you die
that's that's it it's just the worst way
to go I'm glad the ice bucket challenge
is giving ALS all this attention I think
it's a great thing but I was thought
it's kind of stupid to do this gimmick
for charity but it's obviously working
and it's raising a ton of awareness and
a ton of money towards charity so I'm
very glad about that
so that's that's that like I said I'm
gonna donate a thousand dollars and
that's it no no water required it
shouldn't have to do honestly changing
topic when I was away in New Orleans for
holiday I wasn't checking Twitter as
much I wasn't checking Facebook I wasn't
really I couldn't read the comments like
I made sure it was a full holiday where
I don't do all these things that I do on
a regular basis so when I came back and
I read the comments and I do all those
things and I I just felt like you bros
went really there I'm not trying to
offend you bros who show a lot of
support and I really appreciate it but I
don't see it that much anymore I don't
see the same type of support and I make
videos every day for for you bro that's
my reason of wanting to do this and I
think the main problem here is the
comments I know I complain about the
comments a lot but it's basically my
main way to communicate with you bros I
go to the comments and it's mainly spam
it's people self advertising it's people
who's trying to provoke people reply to
Elise just all this stuff that to me it
doesn't mean anything like I don't care
about it I don't want to see it I just
don't care I want to see what you bros
saying or what's going on with you bros
but I don't see that because it get
blocked out by all these things and
it's it's been bothering me for so long
now I've been trying to find solutions
to it I've been hoping that it would get
better I was hoping you two would try to
figure a way out but it doesn't seem
like it and I'm just sick of it so I'm
gonna turn the comments off forever
they're not coming back this time around
and I hope you understand my decision
I'm doing that I wouldn't say as we lose
something I would say it as taking the
next step in the right direction
cuz it's been going on for too long this
comment being [ __ ] and it's just it just
bothers me instead I'm gonna use Twitter
I'm gonna put up a red date
I'm gonna use it as frequently as I can
I'll probably do what I did before I'll
post a hashtag and you guys can tweet me
or whatever about that video that worked
well before and you both seem to like it
I liked it so why not really I just want
to connect with you bros that's that's
all I care about
if you bros support really means
everything to me if I don't feel like
you bros are with me I'm like what's the
point really so thank you for 30 million
subscribers again and thank you for
understanding this decision that's all
for me now I know this is probably not
the most exciting video but I felt like
I had to address these issues but as
always we gotta end up with a bro freeze
so it's a little it's okay
don't cry raise your hand up still
waiting don't touch your junk curb all
right you ready almost and it got shut
up ruin the brofist all right we ready
Brophy